[Music]
if a starfish wore clothes where would
it put its
trousers on two of its arms on all of
its arms on the tube feet it uses to
move it's an interesting hypothetical
but it's also representative of a pretty
fundamental Concept in the evolution of
animal body plans bilateral symmetry
that is to say a body PL with a headend
and a tail end with a symmetrical body
on either side which means for a lot of
animals You could argue that there is a
scientifically accurate answer to the
trouser question the trousers go at the
bottom or tail
end but starfish despite being evolved
from the same ancestors as other
batarians don't seem to have an obvious
tail or head or clear symmetry their
mouth is on the bottom their anus is on
the top no clear place to put a pair of
tra
trowers and yet as lari they do have
bilateral symmetry and that is
particularly perplexing to developmental
biologists generally in the animal
kingdom once you evolve a bilaterally
symmetrical body plan you don't go back
so what's going on well scientists may
now have an answer and they found it by
looking at the genes which encode body
plans but before we get to their
findings let's start with with the
basics bilaterian body plans can be
roughly divided into three sections two
of these are in the head the forbrain
and midbrain shown in red and blue and
the third is the rest of the body the
trunk in yellow at the tail end where
the trousers might go these sections are
generally arranged in a straight line
along the head to tail axis and each
have different Gene Expressions
associated with them so how might this
map onto a five armed
starfish the first theory is a somewhat
cartoonish arrangement with the forbrain
in one arm and the trunk opposite cute
but previous work has already shown that
it's not very likely another theory is
that each of a starfish's arms is in
fact a copy of the basic three-part body
plan duplicated five times and joined at
the heads with a trunk on each
end and another popular theory is that
perhaps the normal head to tail axis
goes from mouth to anus upside down
through the center of the starfish the
forbrain would be at the bottom then the
midbrain then the trunk on
top to settle the debate researchers
mapped gene expression in different bits
of starfish Anatomy looking specifically
for the genes expressed in the forbrain
midbrain and trunk of other
batarians and this is what they came up
with the four brain genes are expressed
in the center reaching out into each arm
around that are the midbrain jees but
the trunk is not
there there is a thin layer of tissue
that expresses the genes normally found
at the boundary between head and trunk
shown here in green but the trunk itself
is absent the starfish is basically all
head
which means at odds with all previous
theories this starfish has nowhere to
put its
trousers the researchers say that this
finding is likely to apply to other
ainad derms as well and it's an
important piece of the puzzle when it
comes to understanding batarian
Evolution and figuring out how strange
creatures like Ain ofms relate to
creatures like
us paleontologists also now have more
information to go back and study the
many strange fossils of a kerms and
their
relatives and in the meantime instead of
a starfish in trousers perhaps we'll
have to settle for a big
[Music]
hat